The joe rogan experience.
Here's the problem with stopping hate
speech is like who's to decide because
they're pushing the boundary. Would
hate speech so far in that, right?
Like if you call a trans woman,
a man that's hate speech like that,
there's,
it's Kinda what did, that's
just an accident. Yeah,
it's still accidental hate
speech. Why? That's crazy.
Because we live in a new world now.
See,
I can't accept that you don't go online
and now if you do it out of malice,
like if you're, if someone's like, Hey,
I'm Margaret, and the guy goes, no, no,
I'm not going to call you that good there,
then that's them being proactively
prejudice. Right? I'm being a dick.
They're being an asshole.
But some people are of the
opinion that this is all nonsense.
But if it's an unknown, but I'm not
sure I'm not taking, taking their point.
But I do want to play devil's advocate
because I've had conversations with
people who are pretty intelligent people
than to say, this is all nonsense.
And then this trans stuff,
and this is,
this is a trendy thing that
people were really getting into.
In summary Bore really distorted.
Like their perceptions of reality is
really distorted and they're being talked
into this because it's a thing
that a lot of people are doing it.
And so they're getting, and
um, I hear that and I go, wow,
I don't know if I believe that people
are willing to transition to another sex
because they're confused. That's
a big leap. It's a giant ass leap.
But here's the other leap.
The leap is you telling someone
whether or not they feel a certain way.
And then the other leap, here's the
other leap. What do you give a fuck
if Bruce Jenner wants to become
Caitlyn Jenner? Okay, I'll call
or Katelyn to, I don't care. But if she
thinks I'm gonna stop making fun of her,
she's out of her fucking okay. That's
what it, but that's what I mean.
So you should be allowed to just,
you should be allowed to mock at a freedom
that you would anyway, every six foot,
three person would size 14 high heels
gets mocked, just listen around the clock.
It, anybody would get made fun of for
any of that in any other way. Yes.
If you used to be a girl or you used
to be a dude and now you're a girl,
someone's gonna make fun of you.
And that's just the price
you pay for being a person.
But people make fun of everyone for
everything. Everything. You have red hair,
right? Is My whole life,
your whole life. But what?
I can't start a group against it being
like people trying enough of this enough.
No, just it is what it is.
Everyone has these slots. The
kick of Ginger Ginger Day.
That wasn't cool. No, but no, but
you know what's so funny about that?
Those guys were so subversive.
What they're doing is showing how quickly
people jump onto things and go, yeah,
fuck them. It's true. Come
on. So they're so smart.
I love that episode because it
was like that could be a real,
and that's how dumb people are.
People in the real world have told me,
been like through it. I wonder where
we kick of Ginger Day is they buy.
That's real to them. But that's,
that's by the way I played,
I played golf with a buddy
at the country club that, uh,
Caitlyn Jenner belongs to.
My first question does,
does she hit from the women's season,
the men's tees? And the guy with me goes,
she hits from the women's taste. I'm
like, Bull Shit. See, that's bullshit.
Is it bullshit dude? Because you, you,
you're a fucking Olympian. You, you were,
you still at the difference between the
men's tees? I mean, like distance 30,
40 yards. Yeah. Ah, yeah.
That's like doing those pushups
on your knees. Bullshit.
Yeah. Good on your toes, but oh, but wait
a minute. He used it. Uh, she, she had,
she has man structured muscle and
didn't go away. That's all gone.
No muscle. There's no muscle. While she's
still pretty fucking jet. Not Really,
man. No, I'm going to be honest, I
don't think she works out at all.
And she's old already.
So it's not like your body has,
I still say you go back to the most taste,
but she still has a Dick, right? Nope.
She had the operation. Cut it off.
It's hollow. Is it gone? Yes. No. Okay.
Now you get women's tees it up.
Dick was there. You gotta go.
You gotta go back to the black.
Yeah.
This is a lot of fence riders out there
in the Trans World. You got to pick it.
You got to pick dude. You gotta come, you
gotta come or go. That's another thing.
They're saying this,
and this I don't agree with this,
is they're saying that if you are a
person who is male and likes women,
if you are unwilling
to date a trans woman,
it's because you are a transphobic bigot,
including if that trans woman
still has a penis. That is,
that's of no regard. You know what
the, you know, the funny thing of the,
of all this is I'm so happy to just
be a CIS gender men, like a fucking,
I'm so happy to not have to worry about
it. I don't have to worry about it.
No one's gonna call me a bigot for not
liking a subsect of a kind of a thing
that I like. I just like a
wall. I like women. That's
all I know. I like, that's it.
I'm fine now. They'll come around
to you soon. Take [inaudible].
They got Bruno Mars.
He didn't see it coming home on that.
What did they say after?
Brutal. I'm writing black
culture. Cultural appropriation.
You see how many people came to his rescue
though? A bunch of people were like,
that's bullshit. He's a musician.
He cores. What has he done?
Was He appropriating black culture?
Zinging awesome. Made good music. Yeah,
that's all he did.
That billionaire songs,
a wonderful song and he made some
fucking great songs. Great artists.
It's bullshit to think that people now
can stab at anything that you're like,
now you're just trying to cause a stir.
They try it.
They take swings at sometimes don't work.
Like remember they were trying to block
Bossy, stop saying yeah, that's right.
Yeah, but like fuck off. Like
okay. Can just put it out.
I just want to put it out there and try
to put it out. It just giving it a shot.
Yeah. Bruno Mars, they shut this down
so fast and he didn't say anything back.
Good for him. That's my favorite
shit. Yeah. It's Kinda like,
you know how like Samsung and
all these other phone companies,
they make ads about I iPhones, you
know, other, all their ads are based on,
fuck I phones and apple never
makes a response. Of course,
that's the coolest movies
to be like, whatever, man.
Okay.